[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
welcome to episode one of think like a
nobel prize winner which is part of
my mission to convey the wisdom
not only the knowledge of some of the
greatest minds in human history and i'm
so honored that they
really you know provided me with this
great gift which i hope will be a gift
not only for my listeners but maybe even
uh for future generations yet unborn to
benefit from the incredible incredible
um accomplishments but the incredible
mental models the the wisdom not just
the uh not just the knowledge which i
think is so important so i thought today
i'd start i read the first chapter of my
book
think like a nobel prize winner now
available everywhere books are sold on
amazon at least and i want to start with
the forward which was graciously
provided by 2017 nobel prize winner
barry parish
and barry wrote the forward along with
james altucher one of my favorite
podcasters of all time uh james uh wrote
the second part of the forward i've got
two four words maybe that's an eight
word uh but i want to read what barry
had to write and i want to encourage you
to please check out the podcast and also
don't forget to subscribe to my main
podcast which is uh into the impossible
that is available wherever podcasts are
sold
so let me start with the forward which
barry calls curiosity killed the cat but
not the scientist
what do the nine scientists in brian
keating's book have in common besides
having a nobel prize
perhaps the most interesting common
attribute is their insatiable
curiosities in different ways curiosity
is the common driving force the
interviewees articulate in their quest
to understand the physical world
each of these very successful scientists
has been strongly driven to understand
the unknown and the unknowable
their very different strengths
weaknesses and approaches to pursuing
the frontiers of science and their own
lives are revealed through selective
articulation from brian's probing
interviews accompanied by brian's own
very interesting and candid reactions
and interpretations
while reading this short book
don't skip the very interesting and
short interstitial chapter called the
scientific method what inspired brian to
write it is unclear but its importance
cannot be overemphasized we deal with
alternate alternate truths and fake news
on a daily basis
aristotle taught us how to use inductive
and deductive reasoning to advance
knowledge and galileo introduced the use
of experiments as a research tool
finally newton in the principia wrote
down his four rules of reasoning which
established the scientific method
now
we rely on statistical arguments to
establish confidence in our experimental
conclusions as well as consensus as
emphasized by keating these same
principles need to be applied to
establishing the truth for societal
questions like global warming or the
effectiveness and risks of coveted
vaccines
lastly i conclude with a personal
observation understanding science is
hard enough understanding scientists is
even harder
as a leading scientist keating deserves
a lot of credit for also tackling the
latter
i couldn't be more pleased to get that
uh that forward from uh from barry
barish james altitude also provided a
very long and delightful forward i will
let you read that in his wonderful
contribution to my book but now i want
to start
with the first chapter which is really
the uh one of only the three chapters
that i wrote introduction this
interstitial chapter that barry
mentioned
and also the conclusion where i take
away and summarize my learnings from
this
journey through the following
chapters in the book
with my heroes of modern science
so i start my introduction with a quote
that inspired the name my podcast the
other podcast you're listening to
hopefully think like a nobel prize
winner i hope you'll rate the podcast
review it etc
and if you're watching this on youtube
please do check out on podcast i won't
be reposting the interviews i did here
on youtube but you can find all the
audio only content on itunes on stitcher
spotify et cetera et cetera and on my
website where you'll find a page
dedicated to think like a nobel prize
winner the podcast and the book with
free bonus material
so i start with arthur c clarke the only
way of discovering the limits of the
possible is to venture a little way past
them into the impossible
when 2017 nobel prize winner barry
barish told me he had suffered from the
imposter syndrome the hair stood up on
the back of my neck
i couldn't believe that one of the most
influential figures in my life and
career
is mortal
is a human being
this shook me to my core because i
thought winning a nobel prize would be
perhaps the greatest accomplishment one
could have and not lead to feelings of
doubt and adequacy certainly and
certainly not the imposter syndrome he
was mortal he was human he sometimes
feels insecure just like i do
every time i'm teaching in the back of
my head i'm thinking who am i to do this
i've always struggled with math and
physics never came naturally to me i got
where i am because of my passion and
curiosity not my s.a.t scores
whereas society venerates the genius
maybe that's you but it's certainly not
me
i've always suffered from the imposter
syndrome discovering that barry parrish
did too even after winning a nobel prize
the highest regard in my field and i
claim in society itself immensely
comforted me
if he was insecure about how he compared
to einstein i wanted to comfort him too
einstein was in awe of isaac newton
saying newton determined the course of
western thought research and practice
like no one else before or since
and newton too had his doubts of
inadequacy
compared to whom did newton feel wholly
inadequate
jesus christ almighty the truth is the
imposter syndrome is just a normal even
healthy dose of inadequacy
as such we can never overcome it or
defeat it nor should we try to but we
can manage it through understanding and
acceptance
hearing about barry's experience allowed
me to do exactly that and i hope by
sharing that message in this book would
also help others manage including you
this was the moment i decided to create
this book
it's not a physics book
these pages are not for aspiring nobel
prize winners mathematicians or any of
my fellow geeks dweebs or nirns
in fact i specifically wrote it for
non-scientists
for those who because of the quotidian
demands of everyday life don't have the
time often to think about the big
picture topics that humans are capable
of exploring
but most of all i hope by humanizing
science as well as scientists by showing
the craft of science as performed by its
master practitioners you my listener my
reader would see common themes emerge
that will boost your creativity stoke
your imagination and most of all help
you overcome barriers that limit your
success such as the imposter syndrome
thereby unlocking your full potential
for out of this multiverse success
and even though i didn't write it for
physicist it's appropriate to consider
why the subjects of this book who are
all physicists why are they good role
models
well i think it's because physicists are
mental swiss army knives a cerebral seal
team six
we dwell in uncertainty we exist to
solve problems and we have a diverse
toolkit while we're not the best
mathematicians just ask a real
mathematician
we're not the best engineers again ask
one of them we're also not the best
writers speakers communicators but no
single group can simultaneously do all
of these disparate tasks so well as the
physicists i've compiled here
that's what makes them worth listening
to and learning from
i sure have
the individuals in this book have
balanced collaboration with competition
all scientists stand on the proverbial
shoulders of giants of past and present
yet some of the most profound moments of
inspiration do breathe magic into the
equations of a single individual at one
unique time
there's a skill to know when to listen
and to know when to talk for you can't
do both at the same time it's often said
that you've been given two ears and one
mouth such that you might talk half as
much as you listen
these scientists have navigated the
challenging waters between focus and
diversity between balancing intellectual
breath with depth and these are
challenges we all face you face them and
i face them whether you're a scientist
or a salesman you sometimes have to
niche down to solve problems imagine
uh trying to solve to imagine trying to
sell every car model ever made you
couldn't do it you have to niche down to
be successful
and yet you also have to have diversity
of expertise and of creative thought so
i wrote this book for everyone who
struggles to balance the mundane with
the sublime
everyone who is attending to the
day-to-day hard work and labor of
whatever craft they are in while also
trying to achieve something greater in
their profession or in life
i wanted to deconstruct the mental
habits and tactics of some of society's
best and brightest minds in order to
share their wisdom with you my readers
and listeners
and i also want to show you that these
men are just like us they struggle with
compromise they wrestle with perfection
and they aspire always to do something
great and we can too
by studying the habits and tactics of
the world's brightest you can recognize
common themes that apply to your life
even if the subject matter itself is as
far removed from your daily life as a
black hole is from a quark
honestly even though i'm a physicist the
work done by most of the laureates in
this book is no more similar to my daily
work as an experimental cosmologist than
it is to yours perhaps the proverbial
avatar the car salesman in omaha
nebraska
and yet i learned as much from them
about the issues common between us as i
did about their individual
accomplishments
this book includes enduring life lessons
applicable to anyone eager to acquire
skills that will apply throughout life
how it all began
a theme pops up throughout these
interviews regarding the connection
between teaching and learning
in the russian language the word for
scientists translates into
one who was taught
that's an awesome responsibility with
many implications
if we were taught we have an obligation
to teach as well but the paradox emerges
as follows to be a good teacher you must
also be a good student you must study
how people learn in order to teach
others effectively
and to learn you must not only study but
also teach to make it enduring
in that way i also have a selfish
motivation behind this book i wanted to
share everything i learned from these
laureates in order to learn it even more
durably myself
mostly however i see this book as an
extension of my duty as an educator
that's also how the podcast into the
impossible began
i view it as many of you may know i view
it as sort of a moral obligation for
scientists who are supported by the
public to give back to the public i
don't do this for
the monetary reward how can a
99 cent ebook really be expected to make
much money for an author no i do it
because i feel a moral obligation to
teach you the tax paying public uh the
lessons that i've learned in words you
can understand in language you can
understand and never ever dumb it down
and this is kind of creating as i say
the free university i wish existed when
i was a kid that you could attend in
your pajamas and incur no student loan
debt
i've always had an insatiable curiosity
about learning and education
combined with the recognition that life
is short
and i wanted to extract as much wisdom
from life as i could while i could
now as a college professor i think of
teachers like myself as shortcuts as
hacks in this endeavor teachers act as a
tool to reduce the amount of time
otherwise required to learn something on
one's own
by compressing and making the learning
process as efficient as possible but no
more so
i think is the best way to accomplish
our duty our role as educators
the word educator means to bring out of
not to pour into in its root language of
latin
in other words there's a value in
wrestling with material that can't be
hacked away so as einstein said make it
as simple as possible but no simpler but
i also think you should make the
learning process as efficient as
possible but no more efficient
as part of my duty as an educator i want
to cultivate a collection of dream
faculty comprised of the minds i wish i
had encountered in my life
the next best thing to having them as my
actual teachers was to learn from their
interviews in a way that distilled their
knowledge philosophy of life their
struggles their tactics and habits into
a digestible easy to consume form and i
started doing that
in 2018 at uc san diego where i am the
co-director of the arthur c clark center
for human imagination in addition to
being the chancellor's the singer's
professor of physics
i realized i had an unfair advantage i
was privileged as part of the clark
center to have access to some of the
greatest minds in human history ranging
from pulitzer prize winners and authors
to ceos to artists and to astronauts
even
as a director co-director of the arthur
clark center i had access to all these
variety of thinkers and writers and
inventors courtesy of our guest speaker
series and that's how into the
impossible really emerged
the list of invited speakers was not at
all limited to scientists and in fact
the common denominator was always
conversations about human curiosity
imagination and communication from a
wide variety of vantage points
i realized it would be a missed
opportunity if only those people who
attended our live events benefited from
these world-class intellects
so we supplemented their visits
when they came with podcast interviews
during which i
alongside eric very my co-the coat the
director of the rfc clark center
and others like stuart walcow
would go into detail with some of the
visiting speakers i started referring to
the podcast as the university i wish i
could have attended in pajamas where we
don't incur student loan debt as i said
so the goal of the podcast is to
interview the greatest minds for the
greatest number of people
and in fact my first guest was the
esteemed physicist freeman dyson
i next interviewed science fiction
authors like andy weir kim stanley
robinson poets and artists including
herbert seguenza and ray armentrout
astronauts such as jessica myer and
nicole stott and many others
along the way i also started to collect
a curated subset of interviews with
nobel prize winning physicists
then in february 2020 my friend freeman
dyson died
dyson was the prototype of a truly
overlooked nobel laureate his
contributions to our understanding of
the fundamentals of matter and energy
cannot be overstated yet he was bypassed
for the nobel prize he surely deserved
i was honored to frequently host him for
his winter visits from princeton to
enjoy la jolla's sublime weather
freeman's death left lent an incredible
sense of urgency to my mission forcing
me to acknowledge that most
prize-winning physicists are getting on
in years
i don't know how to say this in any
other way but i started to feel sick to
my stomach thinking i might miss an
opportunity to talk to some of the most
brilliant minds in history who because
of winning the nobel prize had an
outsized influence on science and
culture
so in 2020 i started reaching out to
them mo said yes although sadly both of
the living female laureate physicists
declined to be interviewed
while that was incredibly disappointed
not to have any female voices in this
book it was still due to the reality of
the situation and it wasn't for me my
lack of trying and i'm going to keep
trying who knows maybe they'll say yes
someday and maybe there'll be more and
more female laureates to come
for the next edition
of this series of interviews so a year
later i had this incredible collection
of legacy interviews with some of the
most celebrated minds on the planet t.s
eliot nobel laureate himself once said
the nobel is a ticket to one's own
funeral no one has ever done anything
after he got it
but no one proves the idea more wrong
that elliot is espousing than the
physicist in this book
it's a rarified group of individuals to
learn from especially when the focus is
on life lessons not their research
it would be a dereliction of my
intellectual duty not to preserve them
and to share them and i'm doing this
with you
still if you read my first book losing
the nobel prize in which i criticized
both the nobel committee as well as a
larger culture that has turned the prize
into a false idol sometimes at the
expense of more meaningful achievement
you may be surprised that i've now
written
an adjacent book with a much sunnier
disposition
after losing the nobel prize was
published some accused me of crying sour
grapes they said i wasn't disingenuous
and there's nothing i'd like better than
to win my own nobel prize
and i always say that one of two things
you can actually prove that i'm a
hypocrite if i am offered a nobel prize
and i accept it so work to do that or
you can also say that calling for reform
of the system can be done without
suggesting we throw the whole system out
we can use the prestige and veneration
of the price to agitate for reform and
to live up to what the prize could be
on the other hand i say of course the
prize already does represent something
almost mystical to millions around the
world and those who have won it have
much to teach and to inspire
why lose that opportunity
this is an important vehicle as
imperfect as it is
nevertheless such responses to the book
led me to engage in some soul searching
about what the prize really means to me
this certainly may have subconsciously
drawn me back to the subject matter
fueling my desire to interview as many
laureates as i could
but regardless i see no contradiction
between my last book and this book
because criticisms have always been
about the committee about the process
about the entrenched discrimination that
may be present within it but never ever
about the recipients themselves they
can't choose themselves so how is it
possible for me to criticize them
the process may be deeply flawed but we
can still use the tools that the nobel
prize provides as a way of learning
about the tactics and habits and tricks
mental models bias overcoming prejudices
etc to improve my life to improve your
life and i hope you will find that as
well
further as you'll see in this book none
of these recipients were ever driven by
the ambition to win the prize and it
makes them an ideal role model some of
them exhibit exceptional patience
waiting decades between what they
discovered and what their recognition
came to and i.e winning the nobel prize
took decades
so i want to know what it is about
people who can endure persevere survive
and thrive and continue to develop new
things in contrast to what elliot said
these are not waiting for the funeral
and doing nothing
these are human beings that are
exceptional that are working harder than
ever in some cases to this very day even
just a few years after winning the nobel
prize so now i want to share
those lessons with you
how to approach this book
this book is not comprised of
transcripts of my interviews they're
actually highly distilled interviews
that content from the interviews i
pulled out the best bits in my opinion
exemplifying traits worthy of emulation
by non-scientists
after each exchange i added context or
shared how it's been affected how i've
been affected by that particular quote
or idea i also edited for clarity since
spoken communication doesn't always
translate directly to the page
all in all i've done my best to maintain
the authenticity of my exchanges with my
guests
for example you'll notice that my
questions don't always relate to the
takeaway conversations sometimes go in
unexpected directions
i could have rephrased the questions for
the book so that they would more
accurately represent the laureate's
responses but i didn't want to
misrepresent any context that they
provided
still as usual any mistakes accidentally
introduced are definitely mine not
theirs
you'll also find that each chapter
contains a nugget a small box briefly
explaining the laureate's prize-winning
work not because there'll be a test or
homework at the end but because it's
interesting context and fascinating
science
and although the book isn't written for
scientists i know a lot of my readers
will
will be scientists want to become
scientists or maybe there are scientists
and those folks will want to learn a bit
about the fascinating scientific subject
matter in these pages
and this again is no surprise from the
people based upon the people that are
teaching you these free lessons
so
if you're not interested in it you can
skip it's to choose your own adventure
but if you're looking for more you can
be referred to laureate's nobel lectures
at nobelprize.org
there you'll find their knowledge but
here you will find it their wisdom
distilled and compressed into
concentrated actionable form
and i've also provided custom-made
illustrations from my friend ray braun
that i commissioned him to do for both
the laureates themselves and a little
juicy nugget a picture uh characterizing
their captivating science i hope you'll
enjoy those
lastly each interview ends with a
handful of lightning round questions
designed to elicit more deep answers to
questions that are provocative or
insight into their character to show you
what they're like in real life as human
beings
often these questions will reoccur
further you'll find several several
recurrent themes from interview to
interview including the power of
curiosity the importance of listening to
your critics and why it's paramount to
pursue goals that are quote unquote
useless
i thought about collecting all the like
with like and pulling all these things
into a separate chapter but i feel the
wisdom will resonate more powerfully
with you
if it appears within the context of each
conversation
like history these chapters don't repeat
but as twain said they do rhyme
feel free to read chapters in whatever
order you like i've designed it to be
read in order but you don't have to you
can choose your own adventure as i say
that will also work perfectly fine one
last disclaimer although these
interviews are with individual winners
no one did their work alone scientists
work in teams and the teams have only
gotten bigger over the decades often
crossing continents and spanning decades
that only three people per discovery are
rewarded with nobel prizes rather than
the entire team remains one of my
biggest criticisms of the nobel
committee and process
as such you'll find not only do i feel
this way most if not all of the
laureates agree with this flaw in the
nobel prize and you'll see i often
repeat as do they
my team their team if they're saying if
they're talking about rr if i'm talking
about it you may find that nauseating ad
nauseam but that's intentional because i
do believe it's one of the biggest flaws
that we overlook the contributions of
teams and i think actually including
teams would do wonders for increasing
the diversity of the nobel prizes
including more women and minorities
and i'll be speaking about that in
future episodes
so what will you learn in this book
you'll find no high level physics here
there's no equations there's no homework
in these pages are years of wisdom
distilled into chunks of actionable
intelligence including examples of
resilience of patience and of courage
you'll learn how to deconstruct the most
vexing problems in your life and see
common threads between widely disparate
separated aspects in your life or career
and hopefully help you weave them
together and find meaning in the
interactions that occur
and the occasional struggles you will
have
either with the subject that you're
dealing with in your life or with people
you collaborate or work with along the
way you'll learn why it's essential not
only to immerse yourself in the past
history of your craft but also to invest
in the future of your field by teaching
the upcoming generations of
practitioners as well
you'll learn the value of patience that
science has a great deal in common with
art and the value in doing something for
its own sake
rather than to receive accolades and
attention
and you'll be powerfully reminded to
allow curiosity beauty and serendipity
to bring joy into your life through the
surprising cracks that open up each time
we turn fresh eyes onto a new problem
why learn these skills from physicists
specifically
first physicists are problem solvers by
design there are also talented observers
of physical reality trained to minimize
their biases
and they've done so by being generalists
by pulling tools from disparate fields
including mathematics logic art
philosophy some even including mysticism
finally their ultimate goal is to make
sense of the universe and our place in
it a goal all humans are eager to pursue
the scientific method is the most
powerful tool to analyze the physical
world around us in that way science
belongs to all of us
perhaps most importantly successful
physicists like the nine featured here
and all have excellent soft skills
they've had to learn how to communicate
and lead often through trial and error
when i ask my students the most
important skills needed to be a
physicist they usually say mathematical
ability or maybe laboratory experimental
skills wrong and wrong
communication skills and emotional
intelligence
are the two most important tools among
the greatest minds in my field
whether it's correlated or causative the
laureates in this book
have the ability to recognize humanity
and that physics is ultimately a science
which can only be done by human
beings but if you learn only one thing
from this book i want it to be that
these geniuses are mere mortals
they suffer from the same foibles
challenges and prejudices that afflict
us all
through these conversations we can learn
how better to deal with the afflictions
ourselves
finally if you learn nothing at all i
believe you'll be inspired
i was directly affected by many of these
laureates early in my career and i was
indirectly affected by others among them
who had inspired my mentors
inspiration is a chain
and my ultimate goal in this podcast in
this book is to lengthen and strengthen
that chain
lastly i'll discuss my favorite one of
my favorite essays or portions of an
essay the crutch of genius
and it reminded me of a scene in the
movie a few good men where colonel
jessup played by jack nicholson barks at
lieutenant cathy played by tom cruise he
says you want me on that wall you need
me on that wall
i've often felt that lay people want to
know that nobel laureates exist more
than they really want to know what they
want the prize for
it's almost as if society like the
fictitious characters and a few good men
sleep better collectively knowing that
such geniuses exist perhaps if only to
desist from doing the hard work
ourselves
it's a form of absolution and comfort to
some to think well so-and-so may be a
physics nerd but they were lucky they
had an unfair advantage they were
genetic or financial birthright status
or otherwise i don't have that advantage
i don't have to do it then
reminds me of what nietzsche said
thus our vanity our self-love promotes
the cult of the genius for only if we
think of him as being very remote from
us as a miraculum does he not aggrieve
us
genius 2 does nothing but learn first
how to lay bricks and then how to build
and continually seek for material and
continually form itself around it
every activity of man is amazingly
complicated not only that of the genius
but none is a miracle and that's from
friedrich nietzsche's human all too
human a book for free spirits
now the laureates themselves
in this book think like a nobel prize
winner are maybe not all what you'd
consider free spirits
but most of them came from humble
backgrounds but they were able to build
solid intellectual walls
showing that genius is often a triumph
of hard work not merely the caprice of
fortune or birthright
to me this is more comforting what one
craftsman can build so can another
that is our task in this book too
brick by brick let us see how it is done
so that's the introduction chapter to
think like a nobel prize winner i hope
you'll pick up the book
on amazon uh it's available in every
format you can imagine please rate it
there review it if you do read it when
we launch it it's going to be 99 cents
uh the ebook version at least the kindle
version so please pick it up you didn't
do it for the money hard to get rich on
99 cents at a time
but i had to price it at something and
that's what we did for the first week of
launch i hope you'll get it i hope you
leave a review there leave a review of
this podcast wherever you're listening
to this podcast or follow subscribe and
don't forget my main podcast channel
which will have more interviews with
nobel laureates and other geniuses
brainiacs billionaires astronauts and
more deepest thinkers the university i
wish existed now it exists for you i'm
doing it for you please send me an email
join my mailing list at primekeating.com
and get the bonus material for this book
uh on those pages for now thanking you
so much for exploring these wonderful
lessons from laureates
into the impossibles spin-off podcast
think like a nobel prize winner
till next time
[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]